time loop stories are super hard to end
and my experience watching this movie
was that I'm loving this movie I am
dreading the ending because it's gonna
be disappointing um how did you did you
guys come up with any like I guess was
the was the ending that's in the film
now always in the script or was that a
really hard process to figure out where
without saying what the other ones were
we definitely went through many drafts
of the ending different versions we even
shot a few different versions
we re edited it a few different ways and
kind of landed on what we had by way of
doing like small friends and family
screenings and pulling people until we
got to one where like three screenings
in a row after the screening we said to
never like the ending and everyone
raised their hands
we're like all right I mean it might not
be perfect but everyone liked it
so time-loop stories are incredibly hard
and like yes I had no idea how it was
going to end in a way that was
satisfying but he did it I think he did
it thank you nicely a lack of trying
I would say what our goal was was since
it's a blend of genres this movie we
wanted an ending that felt satisfying
for the rom-com part of it also not like
a cop-out for the nihilistic existential
dread part of it and also something that
would be not complete gobbledygook for
people who love sci-fi and we're
tracking the rules and the ins and outs
of those types of things so it was a
very difficult needle to thread and
obviously it would have been easy to
push it further into any one of those
three categories and what we ended up
with hopefully is the best version which
was satiating all three in some way
shape or form you did something I hope
everyone agrees